regardez bien
ces bidonvilles que vous avez tous vu
planté sur un terrain de banlieue ou
entassés entre de modeste bâtiment dans
une rue tranquille n'existe plus leurs
habitants des travailleurs sans logement
ont tous trouvé un toit avant leur
destruction
après ces documents photographiques vous
allez avec nous pénétrer dans cet
univers spécial play et des grandes
cités industrielles à lyon à
saint-etienne à valence à grenoble tous
les moyens ont été mis en oeuvre pour
lutter contre ces bidonvilles qui auront
tous disparu dans quelques semaines
combien en reste-t-il exactement dans la
région rhône-alpes et combien il y en
avait et il y a quelques années
c'est ce que nous avons voulu savoir que
reste-t-il comme bidonville de type
traditionnel on n'en trouve plus qu'à
saint-etienne a dans le quartier de méan
et à lyon / commune de solaise et chats
la commune de saint priest
bonjour monsieur vous habiter ici
bien longtemps 4 1 contre un ennemi que
faites-vous trois manches et un peu
l'enfer
vous avez beaucoup d'enfants j'ai trois
filles et deux garçons
voilà une petite touche et quatre fois
les évangiles quatre fois l'hôpital
si c'est pas malheureux pour le voir
parce que la peur soit ils peuvent même
pas les laver le petit caca pour éviter
la sema fischer et livers quand ça se
passe très mal dans la très froid tout
ce qu'on gagne c'est pour acheter du
charbon et jamais on est championne âgée
dé la moitié des enfants
le drakkar détails sont malades jean des
bronchites et jean despas l'onu payer
des frais d'hospitalisation ici toute
une famille de six personnes vit hiver
comme été on n'a pas d'eau rien du tout
et nous on m'a pas permis de fermer un b
c est ce qu il fallait connaître de
mishima y compris un million pour faire
baisser avec des au courage de tous
ça te donne dans les draps ah oui je
sais comment il vous a expliqué le
toujours jeune avait la petite qui était
couché là et puis on râle a mordu au nez
et au bras il a fallu la manière
l'hôpital pour les faire des piges être
alors que demandez-vous du tour nous a
carrément donné que nous allons petit
voyez comme pour les pays émettant dans
une dizaine de milles et ça lui permet
on pouvais je prendrais le payer parce
qu'on est capable on gagne bien notre
vie est ici j'avais ils promettent ils
font des promesses des promesses mais on
n'arrive à rien à voir
ah ah
sûr c'est que pensez vous de ce cas et
bien c'est un cas évidemment tout à fait
anormal qu il n'est pas normal que des
enfants grandissent comme ça dans le
froid dans la malpropreté
ils n'ont pas d'eau ils n'ont pas de
d'hygiène il faudrait que ces plusieurs
d'entre nous moi travaillent gagnent
leur vie
on ne peut pas les repousser dans les
ténèbres extérieures ou les envoyer dans
la lune c'est pas possible vous dépenser
sans compter pour les sans abri votre
association aussi oui notre seul but
c'est notre but statutaire que pensez
vous faire pour ces gens là alors on a
cherché des terrains à la périphérie et
on en a trouvé et on a fait des plus on
a aménagé des sortes de terrains de
camping sur lesquels nous allons poser
des chalets provisoire nous sommes allés
à notre temps des sans abri ont demandé
au logement
elle cherche à nous à 10
si vous trouvez un terrain acheté une
fonction achats l'air depuis le chalet
s'est transformée il sera bientôt
remplacée par une petite maison
que de chemin parcouru depuis 12 ans
vous habitiez vous à cette époque nous
sommes restés un mois et demi après vous
avez et oui oui c'est ça thomas pas de
logement nous avons acheté notre amour
nous avons loué un terrain pour nous m
malheureusement ensuite il a fallu s'en
aller quand il raille t destinés à haïti
mardi
ces tramways étaient sans eau et sans
électricité et boursier italien des
enfants une fille avant d'habiter cette
jolie maison où habitez-vous avant
d'agir dans un bidonville ne laisse un
goût de tram vous avec une trame vous
aviez collet d'enfants à ce moment là
cet est maintenant la tenait du ce
comment jugez-vous dans le wagon a well
fargo vous savez on a mal logés à manta
a pas de chauffage y à pas de loup
l'électricité en a pas
vous êtes content d'être logés ici à
bien le travail et que faites vous vous
voyez bien lire vinicio tout va très
bien
tu es bien j'espère que nous serons
c'est parce que vous êtes très jolie
enfants merci beaucoup